comme valérie la côte merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse au
ministre des transports
les premières annonces du gouvernement
le 19 février dernier sur l'avenir des
trains d'équilibré du territoire n'ont
pas suffi à calmer les inquiétudes des
usagers et des élus locaux qui craignent
un démembrement pure et simple des
trains intercités
c'est bien un sacrifice délibérée de
l'activité ferroviaire qui se prépare
avec des conséquences désastreuses pour
nos territoires pour le quotidien des
français et pour une partie des
franciliens après l'abandon programmé
des trains de nuit des échos interne à
la sncf laisse entendre que l'état
s'apprêterait à alléger drastiquement un
certain nombre de dessertes privant
ainsi des villes moyennes ou plus petit
de leur halte ferroviaire
l'association des villes moyennes de
france c'est d'ailleurs ému il y à
quelques jours du risque d'érosion
irrémédiable du service à ce titre la
ligne paris nevers largement empruntée
par des franciliens doit être confortée
dans la réflexion engagée par le préfet
coordinateur du dossier intercités
aujourd'hui plus de 700 personnes
empruntent en gare de nemours saint
pierre les deux intercités du matin on
ne peut imaginer un report de ses
usagers sur le réseau transilien déjà
complètement saturé la réflexion sur
l'avenir des deux thés ne doit pas se
résumer à un transfert des charges et
des dettes aux conseils régionaux elle
doit faire l'objet d'une concertation
étroite entre l'état les régions y
compris l'île de france et les villes
pour construire un réseau ferroviaire
qui répondent aux attentes de nos
concitoyens
monsieur le ministre ne sacrifiez pas
nos territoires sur l'autel de la seule
rentabilité et de l' équilibre des
comptes de l'état ne multipliez pas les
fractures territoriales en privant des
centaines de milliers de français du
droit de se déplacer pour aller
travailler ou étudier
pouvez vous préciser à la représentation
nationale
vos intentions pour assurer la pérennité
des t notés et pour ne pas condamner nos
villes à regarder passer les trains
mais regarde il a parlé comme monsieur
alain vidalies secrétaire d'état chargé
des transports de la mer et de la pêche
merci monsieur le président madame la
députée je vais essayer de vous rassurer
à la fois sur la méthode est à la fois
sur le pont sur la méthode à l'issue du
rapport de la commission présidée par
monsieur durand et dans laquelle il y
avait toutes les sensibilités qui était
représenté le gouvernement a mis en
oeuvre une réforme des traités qu'il
décline régulièrement il ya eu plusieurs
phases vous avez rappelé je veux
simplement dire que l'engagement du
gouvernement pour l'été ôter ces
dernières semaines il s'est concrétisé
par le lancement d'un appel d'offres
pour du matériel nouveau de 1,5 milliard
+ 130 rames qui ont été commandés
directement alstom en ce qui concerne
les lignes structurantes qui resteront
de la compétence de l'état
ce n'est pas le sens de votre question
mais je les ai rappelés dans une réponse
précédent reste ensuite les négociations
qui ont lieu aujourd'hui avec les
régions pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut qu'il
y ait cette négociation n'est pas qu'on
n'a pas comme objectif de faire
absolument des économies mais mettre un
peu de rationnel un peu de rationnel
dans un système où on a à la fois les
régions qui sont organisatrice et l'état
qui est organisateur lui pour l'été au
thé et avec des lignes qui sont parfois
les mêmes qui parfois se recoupent
simplement dans une discussion
d'ailleurs les présidents de région
quelle que soit leur étiquette politique
sont parfaitement ouvert à cette
discussion donc nous avons aujourd'hui
cette phase
j'ai dit qu'elle s'achèverait le 1er
juillet les réponses sont diverses et en
ce qui concerne paris nevers et la gare
de nemours puisque c'était votre
préoccupation
je peux vous confirmer qu'il n'existe à
ce jour et à ma connaissance aucune
aucun objectif d'avoir une remise en
cause et de l'existence de cette ligne
et de la gare de moore simplement il ya
trois régions qui sont concernés et il
faut que cela négociations ont eu lieu
dont vous pouvez être complètement
rassuré sur les intentions du
gouvernement qui souhaite maintenir
l'été était pour l'équilibré des
territoires
merci la parole est qu'à madame
françoise